it's a millionaire theme our how do you
get to be a millionaire well you talk to
real millionaires and you find out how
they did it and you do what they did how
you get to be skinny talk to skinny
people you find out how they did that
and you're skinny how you be married 67
years talk to people been married 67
years find out how they did that you do
it see this is how life works right it's
called best practices we study what
people are doing that are winning at a
particular area of our life and we
emulate that and then we can go there
does money make you happy no it makes
you more of what you already are if you
are miserable and you get money you will
be miserable on steroids
money does not make you happy but money
gives you options to do wonderful things
for yourself and others called
generosity millionaires have options
that people who aren't millionaires
don't have Rebecca is with us in
Washington DC
Rebecca what's your net worth hi so cool
talk to you my net worth is 1.3 million
cool how's that invested break it down
for me it was actually inherited okay
all of it yes okay cool and how is it
invested its invested I inherited from
my father and it was part of his 401k
okay so it's invested in mutual funds
now in a 401k no it was all in one sock
so in stock okay
stock in a 401k is still there yes okay
I'll go to the pass Oh unfortunately he
passed in May oh I'm so sorry
and how old are you are you 36 okay you
are the first person I've ever spoken to
since doing The Millionaire theme hour
then inherited their money so I really
want to talk to you I heard you asking
ask really glad you called I'm so glad
you called us you know that the
presupposition is the only way to get a
million dollars is to inherit it and you
did it so I finally found somebody that
did it good so tell me the family story
what how did your
dad have money and how much did he leave
in his estate um so my dad grew up on a
farm he worked really hard
he became a electrical engineer and he
did all this on his own he inherited no
money he had his first child and he was
a first generation millionaire yes and
how much money how much money did he
leave when he passed 6.8 Wow and how old
was he he was 70 and a half okay and so
you have brothers and sisters and your
mom or whatever that the 6.8 was
distributed to you're correct yes I have
three other siblings and my mother and
everybody in the picture now is a
millionaire correct
what a legacy he changed his family tree
didn't he yes
mm-hmm Wow he sure did we're doing
everything that you preach okay Wow how
old was he he had just turned 70 this
year okay all right and 6.8 million and
now there's four millionaire's left the
kids and mom yeah and you're one of them
hold are you you told me you said 36
yeah and what do you do for a living I
live in the trade show industry okay so
what did your dad leave you other than
money that says you're not gonna lose
this money say that again what did your
dad leave you in terms of character or
habits that says you're not going to
turn around lose this money integrity he
had a lot of integrity and he always
worked hard and that is one thing that
left such an impression on me and my
siblings all three of you are hard more
money yes very hard okay did you know
you were going to get this money no I
never I didn't actually know how much
money my dad had I never asked him
because it's impolite how I never knew
he had so much money that's wild
yeah yeah and so integrity and hard work
says that at 36 you're going to
take 1.3 and by the time you're his age
it'll be worth and easy right I hope so
yeah yes Wow
okay so really the only the advice you
can give us and I love talking to you
thank you so much for calling in
number one we get to honor your dad
because he obviously was a great dad and
obviously did a great job handling money
both and number two you're the first
person I've ever got to talk to that
actually I'm a millionaire theme our
that actually inherited a million
dollars so this is very cool it's very
large others have who have because the
data that we have says that 12% around
12% of a millionaires are are inherited
and yet I've never talked to one so
they're like a unicorn so far I've just
seen one unicorn and you're it so but
that's so what I guess I guess I need to
ask you what would your dad say if we
asked him can this still be done he
would say yes that was one thing he
always pushed my siblings and I to work
hard save our money and never overspend
that was a big thing for him he never
bought anything new all his cars were
old what do you drive yeah I I Drive a
12-year old Honda Accord okay and are
you gonna go get something different now
no I I would not dishonor him by right
out of the gate buying a new car yeah
yeah so the way you handle this money
going forward will be in an effort to
honor him yes good everything that I
think you would want me to do yeah I
should cuz that'll help keep you on a
good track because he was obviously on a
good track
oh yeah obviously money that's that's a
good way to measure it for you I like
that like it's a good thing from an
integrity and a you know a relationship
standpoint but it's also just a very
practical tool to go hey would dad do
this yeah and if that wouldn't do it we
don't do it cuz that was obviously good
with money so I mean that's a good
that's a good measure you know yeah yeah
very cool very interesting I hadn't
thought about that
you know I'm just thinking about if
somebody doesn't hear it money how to
call them out on it and that's one thing
I would do in the future then if I use
that use that piece of knowledge right
there in the future very glad to help
you well I mean this is incredible
this is absolutely very cool and I also
wanted to say I use one of your endorsed
local providers to help so a property of
ours in Florida and he's been wonderful
that's another thing I'd like to tell
everyone that's listening and these guys
are legit they really do help you they
are 100% there for you yeah so I you
have two brothers yes are both of them
you think going to run the straight and
narrow and handle the money well one of
them odds are I mean really one of the
three of you odds are right so that's
okay probably not yeah one of them I
learn the hard way okay cool how's mom
doing
I'm keep getting there it's a it's been
an uphill climb but she's getting there
and was he ill long or was a sudden
saggy and it was just the other day so
wow this is still resurrect I'm still
very very fresh okay
what a legacy though you know we talk to
people all the time about changing your
family tree don't we I mean the blue guy
called the legacy journey and and here
I'm talking to the tree that has been
changed for forever yeah I mean it's
yeah forever including my nieces and
nephews you know they're going to be
able to go to school pay for because of
what he left us yeah that's very cool
well and again the only way you leave
people money with no character they'll
have no money
if you leave people money with character
they'll end up with 10x the money so
that's why I'm calling you out on 10
million bucks here yeah yeah you need a
10x this now no hurry you got 40 years
you know you got 40 years just invested
steadily like he would have done right
right right
and I don't want to dishonor him at all
I will tell you I'm nervous about it all
being in one star
oh I know I know I said you need to give
you that up that is one of my things
once I am able to get in there okay cool
not don't mess up this story but I just
I want this story to end well so why'd
it go Rebecca thank you for calling in
very interesting so now we've had our
first one
maybe we'll have others now did you
inherit the million because everybody
thinks that everybody inherits it I
finally found one after all these years
this is the Dave Ramsey show hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]